bonsoir merci d'être avec nous comment
vous expliquer le fait que certains soit
exclue justement de cette loi bonsoir
l'expliquer je vais avoir du mal à
l'expliquer parce que je ne le comprends
pas nous faisons tous le même métier
nous avons tous les mêmes difficultés
avec des secteurs différents
la division que crée le gouvernement
depuis le début de septembre où que ce
soit avec l'augmentation salariale pour
les hospitaliers ou d'aprimo qu'ovide
selon selon les établissements et les
services est là pour diviser on a bien
l'impression l'expliquer je peux pas
l'expliquer c'est pas juste les gens
ce mouvement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya de la colère est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment tout de même
d'être entendu vous continuer les
consultations avec le gouvernement
on continue bien sûr parce que je n'ai
pas entendu on n'est pas entendu comme
il se doit en tout cas et on doit
continuer de se battre pour se faire
entendre et faire entendre la voix des
des paramédicaux donc c'est un peu plus
difficile aujourd'hui de mobiliser dans
la rue parce que parce que nous sommes
nous sommes beaucoup pris sur sur mon
boulot respectifs dans nos hôpitaux
parce qu'il manque du personnel malgré
les promesses du ségur d'embauché du
monde dès aujourd'hui les soignants
conduite quitter l'hôpital où il ya
beaucoup aussi de personnels qui sont en
arrêt pour pourquoi vide donc donc c'est
difficile d'aller dans la rue
aujourd'hui mais mais bien sûr qu'on
continue de se battre sur le fond
aujourd'hui vous avez peut-être pas la
réponse à cette question mais ça
concerne combien de personnes justement
qui se trouvent exclus de ce secteur de
la santé est ce que vous avez
connaissance de ce chiffre
non je ne peux pas vous donner de
chiffres un ben c'est pas possible
j'aimais beaucoup trop bien sûr après ce
ségur il faut il faut pas se dire que
c'est terminé c'est c'est un début et on
va continuer pour tout le monde c'est
vrai que nous représentant le collectif
interagences aujourd'hui le collectif
interagences a tendance à vouloir se
s'ouvrir parce que le service des
urgences
c'est aussi bien de travailler avec l'as
moncaco laval donc on va continuer à se
battre pour que ce soit pas une pièce au
cycle à merci noémie le président du
collectif inter urgence d'avoir été avec
nous